foreign
Paul is in New York hey Paul how are you
I'm good how are you Dave better than I
deserve how can we help
yeah so I find myself in a very peculiar
financial situation
um to kind of give you the rundown uh
and I I had a job in Tech and
unfortunately with the tech layoffs this
year
um recently got laid off I was making uh
150 days Plus benefits additionally I do
have a car loan I do have some student
loans which I know are coming back
online soon and then as well as a
personal loan
um thankfully I how much are your
student loans
so um about 20. and how much is your car
loan
uh the remaining principle is twenty
eight five I believe and what's the
personal loan how much uh uh 20 22.5
okay and and now you're unemployed
yes thank you but I do have no credit
card debt I've always treated my credit
card as charge cards so I never carry a
balance
um I do have an emergency fund right now
of about twenty five thousand dollars
um I have a portfolio of
um stock Investments that are
predominantly cash right now in my
brokerage account at about twenty five
thousand dollars and then I also have
which included my Severance in my
checking account I have about 30 30.
okay so the day you get employed you
could write checks and be debt free yep
yeah so there's not a catch though which
is kind of what I'm calling in because
I'm trying to figure out how to best
handle this
um as far as the job goes I'm not too
concerned about finding another job I
think my past experiences will help me
get that I'm kind of grappling with the
thought that it might not be as much
since things are trying to like
normalize right now in the market oh
maybe it's more it's um I think it's
more yeah that would be great I really
do what are you doing Tech
uh so I do um uh business and operation
strategy okay all right yeah so I'm not
a I'm not a uh an engineer or coder
unfortunately but um I I do help the
business side of tech grow
um so
um there's that part
um however the kicker that I mentioned
before is that I
decided to Branch out and I bought a
small business last year you know it was
growing doing very well there's a SBA
loan attached to that which you can
imagine comes with a personal guarantee
how much uh 20 the remaining principle
is 209. all right hold on hold on a
minute we'll come back to you and we'll
talk about this after the break we're
talking to Paul in New York City he's
got about
um
huh he's got about 80 000 bucks in the
bank and he's got about 80 000 bucks in
debt until he opened the business now
he's got 209 in an SBA loan and he lost
his 150 000 Tech job is that a fair
summary what you told me numbers wise
Paul
yeah I do have a 401k but I've listened
to your show long enough to know not to
touch that right so how much how much is
in the 401K
uh 26. okay and how old are you
I'm 29 and what is this business that
you paid
209 000 I borrowed money for
yeah so it's actually a a salon a
Grooming Salon
um so it's it's for for pets okay and
what'd you pay for it
um the uh purchase price was 235 and I
had 12 Equity um as a requirement for
the loan yeah and um what is the net
profit on this business
well when I bought it it was a year
which which I understand was it was
owner operated which you know I'm I kind
of semi-absentee
um it was 120 but with changing business
dynamics that I was not prepared for
it's looking at about
um this year probably like 70 80. what
business Dynamics changed
yeah so I mean one of the advantages
that it had in the beginning was that it
was hourly employees when historically
it's been commissioned employees
um and you know once once things changed
hands and the new year started um
considering how it's a required trade
for people because I'm not I'm not a
groomer myself
um you know they kind of advocated for
commission pay to be at like market rate
and with my hands tied behind my back I
kind of had to like
give in um so that can really contracted
my margins and I'll show you got
confused about who owned it you thought
they did
yeah you know I've never had employees
dictate to me in 30 years I've never had
employees dictate to me when I pay them
yeah you know it's a that's a good point
um and that's the fortunate thing is you
know and I tried to look for
Alternatives and fortunately in the area
that I'm at
um because it's a skilled trade I guess
you have to go to school for it if you
want someone actually good
um you know they're they're that's kind
of like what the market is and I thought
I had more time uh to navigate that but
it came in I think you have I think you
have a business model problem and a comp
problem and a leadership problem in your
small business you need to go solve that
uh you sound like you are a victim to
circumstances and if you're going to
survive in business you can't be a
victim
you've got to get out there and attack
this and go okay I've got to get people
back on the books the way the old owner
had them on the books because everything
you're talking about existed when you
bought this business and the old owner
was running it at 120 and you managed to
make it down to 70 pretty quick so you
got to go clean this up uh and you're
supposed to know business strategy
that's what you're supposed to be doing
at the other place so you've got to go
you got to get your labor straightened
out and it probably means you need to
fire them all systematically not all at
once but you need to get you need to get
a new source of Labor start believing in
the system that you bought originally
and go back and restaff it and you
probably lost these people because they
think that they now think they run the
business they unionized on your some
kind of bull crap here I don't know what
happened and then then you need to get
this thing sold because you are not
equipped to run it
it's running you it's killing you you've
lost half of your value
on this one issue because they LED you
you didn't lead them and you accepted
that the marketplace told you something
and when you're in business you tell the
marketplace things
that's how you do this so you you got to
impose your will man uh and and then
you're going to get at your back back
get get back out there and get your job
at 150 again and then write a check and
pay off all your debts but you need to
sell this thing for 235 if you're lucky
after you get your labor cost
straightened out and um that's what's
going on we deal with this stuff all the
time in entree leadership I do the
entree leadership podcast I take calls
from guys like Paul every day and this
is why you don't borrow money to buy
small businesses SBA Loans are probably
the dumbest thing on the planet second
only to student loans
and so and both government funded by the
way government's going to help small
business out they just help this guy
who's 29 years old doesn't know beans
about anything go two hundred thousand
dollars in debt to buy pet grooming
did you just hear that this is what you
did with your tax dollars okay and now
it's just a you know it wasn't it yeah
no no no no no so you may need to go to
school and learn to pet groom for a
little while and it's almost like he
could have created his own pet grooming
business and earned 209 000 a lot faster
than buying I promise you you know what
I'm saying I promise you yeah I'm not
paying for that yeah that's that's too
easy it's two ease of Entry yeah on
something and that's where we're going
so yeah Paul um you got some serious
moves to make here but part of it is you
got to readjust your mindset and how
you're approaching this so you can get
the value back in this business and then
you need to get it sold
uh you thought you were diversifying and
investing and you weren't
uh you went deeply in debt and as you
said signed it personally so we got to
get you out of that as fast as we can
get you out of it but the best way is
you get the value back in the thing and
then let somebody that wants to be in
the pet grooming business that knows
something about it come along and pay
you what you paid hopefully that owner
for